Pete: Hey it's Pete.
I'm in Shanghai China today and I'm at a very
cool space called Hackerspace where geeks
get together and play with various technology
including a lot of robotics related stuff.
And today I have the pleasure of talking to
Ricky Yi, and Ricky's the founder of a company
called DFRobot and he's going to tell us little
bit about what they're up to in terms of making
Arduino kits which is quite cool, actually.
And, so we're really happy to be here.
Thanks for coming.
Ricky: Thank you
Pete: So, Ricky, first tell me a little about
DFRobot and the high-level of what you guys
do.
Ricky: Right, actually DFRobot started from
2007 and we were probably the first company
to introduce Arduino in China.
And then, we formed the official company in
2008 and started building Ardunio kits and
robots.
And the main target is for education and hobbyists
at the very beginning and then start growing
and target more industry-level focus.
Pete: Great.
So just to set the stage, for all the geeks
out there who might not know what Arduino
is, tell us a little bit about what's cool
about Arduino and what the big deal is.
Ricky: I think Arduino is the open-source
hardware, as everybody knows, and it's first
designed for interactive work.
So, the main purpose of Arduino is to bridge
the gap for software developers and the actual
physical world.
So, it's the link between software and actual
world.
So Arduino is an easy to use board which a
software programmer can just a simple click
a few buttons and burn the programs into the
board and then you have the capability to
control the actual sensors, to read data from
sensors, to control the motors.
And with the motors you can do a lot of things,
it's just based on your imagination.
Pete: Cool.
You have an Arduino board here.
I think this is one of your kits.
Can you just show us briefly what the hardware
looks like?
Ricky: So this is the standard Arduino board,
and you can see it's very simple, and it's
elegant and beautiful.
And here, this is our product, we call this
IO Expansion Shield.
So what this does is to actually expands the
capability of Arduinos.
So you can see it just simply stacks on.
And with this board, you actually can see
there's a lot of pins out which expands the
pins for the Arduino.
And also you have a wireless communication
socket which you can give the Arduino a wireless
communication capability, such as the XB modules
which is very popular in the industry.
Also, this gives you IS 2,3,4 and 5 communication
ports as well.
With this board it's very easy to expand the
capability of Arduino.
And also it's designed for some kits like
this.
This is a joystick module, right.
So with this module you can do a lot of gaming,
you know motion control sort of things.
But with Arduino it's not that easy - you
needed to hardwire a lot of cables to this
module.
But with this IO Expansion Shield all you
need to do is plug on a pin and then write
some code.
Job done.
It's that kind of easy.
Pete: That's great.
So talk to me a little bit about the software
that you use to control these devices.
Is that something very obscure or obtuse?
Or is that - how does that work, when you
want to talk to an Arduino device with software.
Ricky: Basically, we're using standard Arduino
IDE.
It's derived from the Processing language.
Basically it's a Java kind of style of programming
format.
So, I think most programmers, software programmers
can pick that up very easily.
Maybe in an hour or two hours.
What you need to do - it's just a standard
programming IDE.
Write in and type codes.
And what you do is just a standard compile
and upload, and job done.
Pete: Ok, interesting.
And now the Arduino platform is open-source.
I guess I feel like I know what that means
when it comes down to open-source software.
But what is open-source hardware?
What does that mean?
Ricky: Open-source hardware is to, they just
give you all the details about the hardware
such as the schematics to the design file,
probably the layout file, the firmware, also
the BOM which is the bill or material.
So with these four files actually can easy
to put this to a factory and they can manufacture
products based on this file.
So for open-source hardware which means you
can very easy to copy and reproduce the product.
Pete: So, one of these boards, an Arduino
board, costs around what $20 or so?
So if this board costs $20 and you don't want
to spend $20 for every piece of product you
deliver to a customer what you're saying is
you're able to send the specs, send this to
a factory where it can be mass-produced for
much cheaper.
Ricky: Yeah.
I think the most application so far is, say,
using Arduino to do rapid prototyping.
And for mature products design a new board,
maybe based on Arduino, maybe not, for that
purpose you can save a lot of cost because
all the files are open so it's very easy to
modify and reproduce the product.
Pete: That's great.
So it's basically - for those of us who do
startups and understand the whole concept
of rapid iteration, Arduino allows you to
do quicker cycles with hardware.
Is that right?
Ricky: That's correct, yeah.
Pete: So, when it comes down to real-world
products and applications is Arduino just
something for geeks who like robots?
Or is there some real-world applications that
you've seen in the market that are interesting?
Ricky: I mean, if you know Arduino you know
how Arduino is applied in various types of
works such as interactive art, education,
robotics, even home automation as well.
But, that's the past.
From last year we've had several customers
actually come to us looking for code developed
for an industry product.
The recent finished product is called a stomach
probe product, which using an industry stomach
probe.
Pete: A stomach probe?
Ricky: Yeah, stomach probe.
So they actually have asked a company, so
a traditional company, using a PRC or a micro
controller to the development, and they figure
out the cost and the development time is not
a good thing.
And such as for a standard one is like twelve
months.
And for us, I mean we saved the time to one
month - we finished the project in one month.
And then we saved the cost to about 1/5.
Which is great.
Pete: So there're arguably ways to put real
products in the market based on Arduino technology
that already supports certain kinds of standards,
standards compliance, etc.
Ricky: Yes, that's right because Arduino itself
has already passed all the tests.
So the design is mature and reliable.
And the second case is we recently working
with a company which is trying to design Segway
style transportation tools.
And they designed for a ? actually, and they're
using Arduino as the main controller.
And they sell 5,000 in a year for that product
based on Arduino.
That's an amazing thing.
Pete: Well I find it fascinating as an entrepreneur
and a geek myself that the Arduino platform
allows me to create hardware based solutions
and then send them off for manufacturing and,
potentially, even as a low capital style,
lean startup operation, produce a real-world
useful hardware based solution.
That's fascinating.
Ricky: Yeah, that's the biggest part of Arduino
- that's the spirit of Arduino.
Using Arduino you can produce a lot of end
applications, not the half-product application.
We think Arduino is, in the industry level,
it's just in the middle.
It gives you the capability to do rapid prototyping,
to do research, but it's not used for the
end product.
Pete: Right.
So, do you think if I come up with a really
cool application, a hardware based application,
solution, that Foxconn will want my business?
Ricky: Yeah, definitely.
If you have such an idea you can use Arduino
to do the prototyping and then they'll manufacture.
Pete: That's great - very cool.